good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Monday hope
everybody's having a great day thus far
hope everybody enjoyed their weekend hey
Jax how you doing I'm doing good I'm
looking forward to the toast today um a
little you know Monday buoying is in
store yes but we had a very nice weekend
because I had my book signing in New
Jersey on Saturday and as much as in my
head I was just like this is not going
to be the vibe it was the nicest place
on Earth first of all the bookstore that
the signing was at books and greetings
was an oasis if you live anywhere near
that place go there every day like I
would live there no it was huge they had
so many offerings besides books they had
snacks they sold candles and journals
and things for kids it was so cute it
was so cute they sold like blankets it
was such a Vibe I can't even begin to
describe to you and then the people who
showed up were just the best of their
elk really they were the elk of dreamers
they were the elk of amazing people yeah
it was a fabulous um event I was there
too so many people brought their kids
their kids were so cute everybody loved
the book it was ex I agree like we were
thinking like could this event have come
at a worst time like we just had the
worst week we were so I was literally
like not okay last week like so
emotional so nuts like I was not okay I
didn't even realize until like I had the
weekend off it didn't like hit me how
not okay I was until I took time off to
just like think and relax and it turned
out to be just exactly what we needed it
really really was it was so booing it
was so hopeful and positive and thank
you to every single person who came I
enjoyed meeting every single one of you
and your campers were the cutest camp
like those campers were booing me yeah
and to everyone who has bought the book
so far who's tagging me in all their
stories like that it's it's just so
crazy the highs and lows of this week
because that has been such a high for me
but it's also just made me so emotional
so just thank you to everyone the book
will be restocked this week I will share
the link as soon as it hits you know the
stores um so if you didn't get your copy
yet feel just wait till um this week oh
I'm like firing in all cylinders with my
with your no with my noises but if you
want like a true signed copy I signed a
lot of extras for books and greetings so
call them up and order a copy CU that
one is you know like not a book plate
book signed and they can ship too they
can ship and that's the only place right
now that has books in stock fabulous
well it really was great that was a Bo
event I also went to um on Saturday I
wasn't going to go but then I was like
you know what I have to I went to an
engagement party for my friends who are
actually supposed to be getting married
in Israel next year um and that's just
like so Jewish like you you still go and
you still celebrate Simas no you have to
it's like it's mandated really and I was
so I had the best time and it was just
so good to be around like my people so
they were like I I feel so much better
today um I feel like equipped to do the
show I definitely needed the weekend and
I'm glad that I took it and yeah I feel
better I definitely feel different okay
good I'm glad and I also feel like this
tug of war but also a strong resolve
like every time I go through the tug I
end up on the same side of like we have
to move forward obviously like we're
going to this is always going to be top
of mind for us but like we have to keep
working we have to keep doing our show
we have to keep putting smiles on
people's faces and like even the things
that we did like cared about so much two
weeks ago that we don't really care
about like we have to find ways to
engage with them again like it this
can't snc us as like people as a show
like we we Hamas can't take the toast no
for sure and that's like the general
feeling that I'm feeling like I the
things that I cared about that like last
week you couldn't find me like I I'm
coming back to myself like I am caring
like and honestly like the joy and like
the serotonin and the things that I felt
over the weekend when I saw pictures of
Taylor and Travis like was real like
okay that's your first story and we're
going to we're going to we're going to
try and get back to that place yeah no I
I feel like last week it felt like I I
could I would never get there like I
like nothing was important and I think a
lot now that I've like had time to
reflect I think a lot of what I was
feeling for other people was like almost
a resentment like it felt for me like my
whole world was ending like nothing
would ever be the same and then seeing
people just kind of appearing to be
doing things like that they had planned
I was like I was jealous honestly like
resentful almost because for me like
nothing could go on you know yeah no
that's how I feel I feel jealous of
people who don't seem to be affected by
this like I feel jealous that they're
you know at the pumpkin patch just
resuming normal life and so I think like
I was lashing out like for real like I
was
jealous you mean of tayor and her
premiere of Taylor and just like my
whole um like energy like being angry at
everyone you know I I I think it was
like a genuine resentment yeah so you
don't feel that way today I'm I'm I'm
definitely feeling better like I I'm
feeling better okay I don't know if I
can pinpoint like exactly how I feel
about everything but right now I'm like
acknowledging my resentment okay that's
fair you know it's going to come in
waves so like I didn't even I didn't get
to see the eras movie like I I had all
these plans remember right and I ended
up just giving all my tickets away yeah
well it'll be there waiting for you
whenever you're ready and I really I
want to enjoy it like and I want to be
in a really good place to enjoy it and
so I don't know when that is but like I
will be seeing it of course okay good
good yeah cuz you know and that's the
thing like with tillor specifically like
tillor has brought me so much joy over
the years and like I don't want that to
dissipate like then who then we're all
losers yeah I think you do need to like
hold on to those things and try
and still care if you can and it seems
like you can you're getting to a place I
can I can I really needed this weekend
and I feel like this is going to be a
really good week and and I want to have
hope well you have a great week why
don't you tell everyone about your week
well I well today's episode by the way
is audio only because chy is booked and
busy it's literally the crack of dawn
I'm in full Glam I am headed to two
events and then to the airport so I will
get to La later today and then starts my
big week you know I've got Jackie
Shimmel on the toast I've got Heather
mcdonal on the toast I'm doing a bunch
of things in La you know meetings
meetings meetings podcast podcast
podcast so it's going to be a very when
I'm I don't go to La a lot so when I do
I try and do everything like a normal
person would do every time they go to La
but I do it like once or twice a year
and so that's what this week is like I
know I'm going to be dead when I get
home but um it'll be good I'm really
excited it'll be productive I think
it'll be good for me to like get out of
the house and then when I get back I
literally move like things are I I I I
was literally thinking with Ben last
night I'm like we haven't even thought
or talked about mov moving because we've
been so you know focused on other more
important things but that's something
I'm really excited about and that's
booing me like that's something I've
wanted for so long like and I'm really
excited I'm excited for the change for
you and the new Energy new energy and I
was saying to Ben the thought of ever
leaving my current apartment and my
building and the people who work here
and my neighbors like for so long it was
it made me like so sad I think it
actually hindered me from ever moving
out the previous times that I've tried
that we all know about and now I feel so
excited about my new place that like a
lot of that sadness isn't there yeah
great yeah so I'm just I'm being
positive like I'm really trying
to look forward okay that's I love that
thank
you um we actually have some really good
stories today so I'm excited to get into
it obviously the big news of the weekend
was Taylor and Travis's
NYC johs they were everywhere um so we
will be giving our thoughts beyond that
did you consume any content I I've been
watching Beckham loving it loving it
very interesting stuff and it's so even
more interesting because I don't know
how the games are going to end like are
they going to win the trifecta of the
European Cup I don't know is he going to
go to Real Madrid like this time I don't
know so it's um it's like very
suspenseful for me yeah like having no
knowledge or context makes it even more
exciting yeah and I feel like they do a
good job of you know not spoiling it
like the viewer they made it for a
viewer who might not know what happened
I felt the exact same way I'm so glad
you're watching and enjoying something
that I recommended because I'm watching
something and enjoying that you
recommended which is at home with the
furries like on I forget maybe Friday I
was like I absolutely have to get off my
phone I'm averaging like 13 hours of
screen time it's really not healthy I
need mindless and so I started watching
the furies and I totally get it like
what an interesting group of people what
an interesting life yeah well we were in
the car on the way home from the book
signing and we were talking about oh
because Tommy fought on Saturday yes yes
yes that's why we were talking about it
me you and Ben that's why we were
talking about the furies and Ben was
talking about how he loves Tyson Fury
and this video of him singing um
American Pie we didn't know what he was
talking about and he like kept trying to
pull up the video and like nobody wants
to watch a video in the car like stop no
and like Ben was driving and it's like
stop like every time he hit a red light
he's like let me get this thing and it
was just honestly I started to hate the
video before I even saw it and I was
like this is going to make me this is
going to make me hate Tyson Fury because
Ben is being stupid me too but then he
got the video up and we watched it and
it was iconic and honestly you
recommended but that video like pushed
me over the edge I'm like oh my God
these people are insane I absolutely
need to watch this yeah so you started
it what do you think I think it's a
really good show I do sense like a a a
pattern and the show feels like a little
repetitive cuz it's like he's
retired oh he hates it like it's just
she she puts up with a lot like it's the
for every episode's like kind of similar
but when you're looking for that sort of
mindlessness it's nice to know what's to
come it's comforting yeah and by the way
spoiler alert he's out of retirement
like uh you told me that so I figured
that was coming um but just a very
interesting way of life and I'm learning
lot a lot about the traveler life I had
assumed like Travelers and Roman gypsies
I thought that was a religion but it's
not because they also said that they
were doing a christening like they're
Christian
so it's more like a way of life yeah I
don't
understand it completely I wish they
would explain it more like that it feels
like they expect you to have a basic
understanding of what it means I didn't
even know the term traveler was what you
call Gypsy so I could use a little bit
more of an education but I was enjoying
it too maybe I'll go back to that it was
it was hilarious like it's crazy and
like where do they live honestly I had
to Google I'm like monome or whatever
they live I'm like is and I really can't
distinguish their accents from like I'm
not good with accents so I'm like this
sounds kind of Britain is but like it
also sounds like Scottish and where is
it I believe it's outside of Manchester
yeah it's like Britain is yeah cuz she
went to London for the day to do that
talk show which I loved right Queen
working Mama of like seven oh I'm sorry
do you know who she reminds me of has
anyone else made this call who Britney
Mahomes oh yeah they have like similar
Li lives lives I can never say the word
multiple life lives at least you're not
messing up woman women yeah they have
very similar you know structures of
their day and they kind of look alike I
feel that oh good okay it's also crazy
how young Tyson and Paris are compared
to how many kids they have and like how
much life they've lived yeah they're
like 35 and then of course like the
Tommy and Molly elements are just
fabulous yeah I just finished Molly's
book it was really cute it was a weird
book to be reading you know in the
middle of a war but it was but it was a
light Fair which I guess was good my
only gripe with it which isn't a gripe
with the actual book is that she wrote
it before she was a mama and I love her
so much because of like how she shares
motherhood so it was missing a huge
chunk of Molly for me yeah I feel that
but there was some like there was some
good tidbits about love Island and such
and it was cute no they're interesting
so I watched that I watched a lot of the
nanny a lot of young Sheldon like things
that just bring me you know Solace and
comfort and peace and it was a good
restorative weekend and I'm ready I'm
ready okay I'm ready come and find me
should we get into the stories then like
are you are you that ready I mean I do
have like a busy day so yeah okay okay
good so without further ad Doo here are
the fast five stories that you need to
know and today's episode of the toast is
brought to you by saks.com we are always
doing our best when it comes to looking
fabulous on the podcast sometimes our
pajama uniforms and sweatshirts do need
a little bit of an upgrade and that's
why love shopping at sax.com for
everything from podcast lops to gno fits
and more let we not forget this is my
year of yes and that means you know
events trips and that requires clothing
and it is so hard for me these days I
just did a whole Vlog yesterday about
this it is really hard for me to find
clothing and sax.com is one of my
favorites you know as a New Yorker we
know it's an institution and I love
their website it's super fun and easy to
shop on so whether you're going for a
cozy Vibe a more elevated look they've
got it all at sax.com because don't get
don't get it twisted once I move into my
new apartment like my cozy Vibes are
going to be on fleek you you guys are
not going to recognize me that's because
I'm shopping at sax.com and what I love
about sax.com is they have really
specific filters so whether you're like
a wedding guest you're going on vacation
you need something for a business they
make it really easy to shop and they get
a little crazy you know you can even
shop by your star sign or of course by
your situation for like a vacation or
something so you can find the perfect
Revenge dress from Brands like
Christopher esber and cult Gia that's
also why I love sax.com I feel like the
buyers there are all like really Chic so
they find cool new brands and then
you're wearing them before everyone else
and they're like how did you know about
that and you say well well I shop at
sox.com so discover new ways to shop for
everything every day at sax.com that's
saks.com and discover new ways to shop
for everything every day at sax.com
today's episode is also brought to you
by neutral did you know that hair
thinning will happen to approximately
one in two women one of them being your
girl in this case two in two women
because Jackie postpartum energy me with
my you know huge change in diet if
you're among them know that you're not
alone thinning is totally normal and
neutral helps women address it from
within with science-backed supplements
so if you've ever wished for visibly
thicker hair or less shedding or maybe
you're just stressing you out and your
hair is not doing what it needs to be
doing check out neutral the number one
dermatologist recommended hair growth
supplement clinically shown to improve
visible thickness and strength from
postpartum to menopause to plant-based
Lifestyles and no matter your life stage
nutrifol has four unique formulas to
support women each is physician
formulated using drug-free descience
back ingredients so you get the most
reliable results every time go to neutri
fall.com to take their hair Health
Wellness quiz identify the causes of
your thinning hair and nutrifol will
give you personalized plans for better
hair growth through their whole body
approach I like taking the quiz because
I really at the time didn't know that
like a a significant weight loss or a
significant change in diet could have
any sort of repercussions on my hair I
was like shook um so nutrifol just
supporting healthy hair growth from
within by targeting the root causes of
thinning which can be hormones
environment nutrition lifestyle
metabolism take the first step to
visibly thicker healthier hair for
limited time neutral is offering our
listeners $10 off their first month
subscription and free shipping when you
go to neutri fall.com and enter promo
code the toast find out why over 4,000
Healthcare professionals recommend
neutral for healthier hair nutrifol nut
R A f.com promo code th toast that's
neutr fall.com promo code th toast
today's episode is also brought to you
by Thrive Market our go-to for all of
our grocery and household essentials and
the convenience of getting everything
online and then quickly Shi to our
doorstep is a huge time time saer
especially for the mama here mama I know
Thrive Market saves your life it does
cuz not only do I not have to Lug
groceries from the grocery store they
have everything I need and the healthier
versions of it it really couldn't be
better I get all of my cooking
essentials from there I get snacks for
the whole family and I just load up they
also have a freezer section so you can
load up a freezer box frozen pizzas mac
and cheese like they have everything and
as a Thrive Market member we're saving
money on every single grocery order on
average we're saving 30% each time on
top of all the savings they also have a
deals page it changes daily and it gives
you cash back on so many Brands and they
have a price match guarantee so not only
does thrive Market save us money they
also save us time because instead of
reaching reading a bunch of label
ingredients at the grocery store we can
use their on-site filters to suit our
needs so whether you're looking for sud
toied gluten-free snacks low sugar
Alternatives non-toxic cleaning you can
curate your own shopping experience with
the click of a button and trust that
it's made with the highest quality
ingredients and sourcing methods plus
the best part is when you join Thrive
Market you're also helping a family in
need with the one forone membership
matching program so you join and they
give join in on the savings with Thrive
market today and get 30% off your first
order plus a free $60 gift when you go
to thrivemarket.com
theeast for 30% off your first order
plus a free $60 gift that's t h r i v
market.com theeast thrivemarket.com
theeast okay let's get into the stories
our first story is the big news of the
weekend Taylor Swift and Travis Kelce
get touchy fely during a second date
night in a row during their Whirlwind
New York weekend they were spotted out
for dinner on Saturday night they both
made cameos on SNL Sunday night they
went to dinner again after Travis was
seen leaving her apartment to go to the
Eagles game vers the Jets to watch his
brother play the Jets so this was like
the first time we like really got
pictures of them together you know yes
intentional and it was crazy cuz we got
pictures and videos and the way that
people have broken down every
millisecond of this video is insane but
it is that interesting like it really is
it was a long walk it was a long walk
there was a lot of action the door the
guards the paparazzi like there was a
lot to unpack and so many people are
comparing it to like a smut novel and I
cannot it's lit it's literally a smut
novel let me tell you why please tell me
why okay in these smut novels like it's
it's really like all about the female
gaze and like so many little things that
like mean more and so like Taylor's
doors are always opened by her security
guard and like Travis wouldn't let that
and like that's so SM where like one guy
who's obsessed with a girl like get out
of my way like it's literally smut and
then just like small things like people
were obsessed with like she got out of
the car he had opened the door for her
she got out of the car and while he's
like waiting for her to walk he closes
the door but he doesn't want to let go
of her so he puts his hand on her
stomach and like hand on the stomach
like that's not usual like usually it's
like hand on you know the small of your
back but it being on the stomach is like
so intimate and it's so smut it's like a
small thing in a smut novel that's
really written from the female gaze cuz
it's like so protective
and Travis is like this enormous guy
he's like a footballer like his job is
to protect and defend and it literally
like you can't write stuff like this and
I saw Tessa Bailey who's one of my
favorite smut writers like on Instagram
like making a video like the smut
ification of Taylor and Travis and
what's so crazy is like we've never seen
Taylor like this like she's always with
freaks like tiny little men who
literally couldn't protect her from [__]
and there's this photo that like has
made the rounds of the universe like the
one time it's like a blurry it's not
Paparazzi it's definitely like an iPhone
photo of Taylor and Joe aln like out to
dinner and they're sitting at a table
that's like one side of the table is a
booth and the other side is the chair
and like the girl always gets the booth
right like that's just that's how it
should be my husband and I have this
conversation all the time Taylor's
literally sitting on the chair and like
she's taller than him and it's just like
it's indicative of like the two
different types of relationships she's
had and how this one is so different
like she's with someone who she can wear
heels with you know for sure we'll talk
about the heels but I just want to say
about the chair thing celebrities do
like to like not
and just because it justs ATT that's
just like her cross to bear as the
famous One Fair the thing with her and
Travis it's like she can have the booth
cuz regardless they're both big stars
there's no stopping people from looking
at them yeah so just the dichotomy of
like everything we've seen in her
previous relationships compared to this
like it's smut in the making it is plus
she gets to wear her heels which
everyone was freaking out about cuz he's
still so much taller than her and it's a
dream did you see the pictures of his
closeup of his mustache when they let so
they were walking into the SNL after
party which is where the stomach
grabbing happened then hours later they
left the SNL after
party and what are you going to say was
that where this I thought the stomach
grab happened like going into
noou so I had seen them go to noou and
then I also saw them walk somewhere else
that looked to be a behind noou I think
that might have been where the
Afterparty was like I was confused part
was at catch I believe I believe that's
not even remotely close to noou yeah
that's what I think I saw okay
interesting interesting
um whatever sorry not to trip you up I
know that's a no no no you're fine
honestly the the like Geographic
locations of the evening did confuse me
cuz I recognized immediately it would be
dinner at noou go to SNL at 30 Rock head
downtown to catch oh dinner was before I
forgot SNL's very late I think dinner
was before oh that makes complete sense
SNL is Uptown no 57 is uptown yes that's
exactly what happened okay cool cool
glad that we can map it out and where
did they go to dinner last night Waverly
in which is Taylor's one of Taylor's
favorite spots got it so after the SNL
after party they're leaving and if you
zoom in on the photos Taylor's upper lip
you know she always loves a sharp red
lip it's a little smudged and you know
that could happen if you get a little
sweaty eat something you drink something
but it's notable that t um Travis's
upper lip has a a stain of red on it so
these two were CLE clearly making out he
also appeared to have like a little
foundation on his upper lip which is my
favorite thing like remember when Kylie
was spotted leaving the movie theaters
with Jaden Smith and he literally had
Foundation all over his face cuz she had
like caked it on and they were making
out so hard because they were literally
14 yeah even um in these pictures of her
entering or leaving Waverly in her nose
is um red red like the the foundation
came off her nose that's classic make
out stuff Jackie it's classic smut like
they can't keep their hands off each
other in public so run to the car like
it's smut and I'm like it's really it's
actually amazing to see someone like
living out of fantasy and I have to
imagine it's even better in real life
honestly yeah just she's obsessed with
him she's obsessed with him and I think
he's obsessed with her and the idea of
her for sure I literally saw a tweet
that was so funny it's like Travis Kelce
had a friendship bracelet and a dream he
has the elk of a dreamer okay yes more
so than the people of California no they
are the elk of dreamers they're not but
I mean it's easy to dream when you look
like him and like you really could get
any girl in the world like any girl who
heard Travis Kel's interested in you
like who wouldn't give it a shot no and
when it first happened I was like this
is amazing like going to love this fling
but like I could see these two getting
married now like I'm I'm fully like
obsessed I still I'm not there yet I I'm
I'm like very into them as a couple but
I do still feel like it's a a fun for
right now sort of thing but these
pictures have moved the needle in terms
of convin see me of their veracity I
will say and then there were the
pictures last night that were like less
exciting because we've it wasn't the
first time um and there wasn't like you
know a belly touching moment however
they were exciting nonetheless and
something I'm really noticing is like
Taylor's style she's like a she used to
like never dressed sexy like not even
close and she's kind of like being like
a little sexy now like with a corset
like what she wore on SNL very tight
corset with like the revealing sides
yeah and she wore a corset to the game
that she went to she's embracing like
you know a a sexier Luke and I'm
definitely here for it well then maybe
her next like album and era will be a
sexy era we haven't had that yet no
vigilante [__] was like was a was a
bridge to some sort of sexiness just one
song like midnights the vibe wasn't sexy
it was like sparkly sparkly I I honestly
when I think I think of groovy as like
the Midnight's Vibe I think of like a
dress you would wear for New Year's
Eve interesting I don't think that I
think of like kind of what she was
wearing in like anti-hero like very 70s
like Fleetwood Mac Daisy Jones yes yes
no that is correct I maybe just cuz the
name midnights I think of like a sparkly
blue dress yeah I do stand by that I did
not like the Luke to the eras Premiere I
was speaking in anger and jealousy but I
I did not like that it wasn't my
favorite no I I think that's fair yeah
um so so yeah it was just like a lot
between SNL did a skit about like the
NFL not being okay which was very on
point like it was it was well well
researched and it was a crazy weekend
like it it really was and honestly I
feel in part it brought me back to life
for real I'm so glad yeah it's important
to have hobbies it is it is for me it's
like I'm I'm I want to be back there so
I'm going to force myself to
re-engage um but it's not the thing but
it was it was never the thing for me
it's more of a thing you know yeah yeah
our next story is kind of a really big
story because it's the story that's been
evading everyone last Friday we had a
fourth story that I forgot to share we
realized after you guys and it was the
story that I was talking about at the
top of the show is about like some
content news that was going to buoy me
oh yeah and I wanted to talk about it
and I got a lot a lot of people like saw
the note on the show was like four we
forgot to sh
so now we're going to share it because I
want to talk about it lessons in
chemistry author talks changes from book
to series she said I'm not going to
compare so lessons in chemistry by
Bonnie Garis which was a redheads book
last year it was one of our top books of
the year and it is now an Apple TV Plus
show and it was an amazing book the
author Barney Garis said that she's
happy to let go a little bit when it
came to adapting her book for TV she
spoke with people for this week's issue
amid the release of the show um she said
I thought oh my gosh what if they
changed X Y and Z they did change X Y
and Z and you know what I'm still living
and breathing it's fine she said as a
writer you want everything to be as you
saw it but you know going in that it
can't be that way so it's just smart to
say no let them go because you can't
demand that they stick with your vision
among some of the changes that are um in
the episode there's a pageant series
storyline in the first episode I guess
like Elizabeth in the show like grows up
doing pageants I guess that could
explain like her
later no that literally makes no [__]
sense I know but they you know Hollywood
she's like this very quirky nerdy like
she would never no but like maybe she
was forced into pageant that's why she
is so like uh upright and rigid and
like no I literally think that's like a
bad call I think I thought it was like
abundantly clear why she was the way
that she was she was very academic very
smart I think she probably had like
Asbergers yeah right like some sort of
social anxiety where she would like say
things that most people would never say
yeah yeah and not in a mean way just in
an observant way right right that's like
um Abed from Community which it's also
like Sheldon yes yes right and Sheldon
didn't grow up doing pageants like right
I mean we'll see how they work it in but
also the way 6:30 is portrayed 6:30 is
the dog from the book he's the breakout
star so Bonnie said 630 is quite
different noting that the dog was going
to be a mountain to climb as he's a hard
character to get down he is because like
we're not going to have a talking dog
but no yeah so in the when it's written
like the dog like getting to hear the
dog's thoughts is interesting in a movie
it's incredibly stupid right so 630 like
can't be as much of a main character
maybe he'll cut cuddle up to mad you
know and do cute dog things but like we
can't know like how many words 630 knows
well honestly it sounds like the author
has like a good grip on this situation I
feel like when you're really close to it
I feel like we've heard a lot of stories
where like the authors are mad it's like
when you sell the rights you sell the
rights and you have to like just move on
from it yeah even though for a lot of
people it's like really personal she has
a Healthy Outlook the first two episodes
are out and then they're dropping every
Friday I'm definitely going to watch I
might just like wait to bank some more
episodes well you know that they like
split up episodes and put like two
minutes on Tik Tok and if you scroll
long enough you can watch the whole
episode oh I've seen a lot cuz I just I
was curious and then once I engage with
the video they send me part two part
three part four and it looks exactly how
how I had pictured it in my head Brie
Larson plays the main character and I
can't decide cuz I I didn't love the
book and mostly it was because I [__]
hated the main character she was so like
just follow the rules follow the rules
um so Brie Larson was bothering me and I
felt like she wasn't doing a good job
but I don't know if that's just from my
general dislike of the main character I
understand like for me the main
character ruined the book I liked
Elizabeth she wasn't my favorite but she
was a good main character and then I
love 6:30 love 6:30 H the cutest I'm
really excited to watch and I was
excited to let you know what Bonnie gas
thought about
um her book being made into a feature
show I'm glad we got to like close the
cycle on that yeah and I know people
were like waiting with baited breath
what was the fourth story that was the
fourth story I'm actually going to move
some things around because I have a
great segue another book to TV news
story this one's Making Waves because
the Hunger Games director said that he
totally toally regrets splitting mocking
jay into two films thank you sir wow
it's so crazy cuz I've seen all the
Hunger Games I didn't know this was like
a a thing within the community it's kind
of like Breaking Dawn uh part one but I
have no problem with that yeah because
like we just wanted more content and
they did a really good job of like
making them two completely different
movies like I couldn't even I would say
Breaking Dawn part one is better only
because we got Bella and Edward's
wedding and like that's all we were
waiting for but they were both that
twist at the end of part two like those
are two equally amazing movies the only
issue with them is like one of them is
called Breaking Dawn Part One like they
needed two different names I I
completely but there are only five books
that's the thing I know but they could
have like plucked something like um what
was part one about it was about like the
wedding like it could have been
something about like and the pregnancy
yeah something about their love take a
quote from an earlier book you know yeah
actually the names don't bother me like
for real um and I forgot that Twilight
did it and Hunger Games did it at like
the exact same time it must have been
like trendy to like split your movie in
half what do you think is bigger
Twilight or like or Hunger Games for me
it's like so obviously Twilight but
that's because I'm obsessed with
Twilight and not Hunger Games I agree
with you that it's that way for me too
but I do think when you get down to
Brass tax Twilight is bigger so are you
saying it's more personal than comedy
yeah and I don't know how you would
measure it like we could go by like box
office or book solds book sales but also
it's like I feel like and this could
just be like my personal bias I feel
like people are always rewatching
Twilight and I yes I sometimes will
watch Hunger Games if it's on but like
it doesn't I don't feel like I need to
rewatch it all the time I feel like
Hunger Games is something you watch for
the plot I got it thank you moving on
Twilight like I watch for the content
yeah I've seen Hunger Games once I have
seen Twilight no short of 50 times yeah
and I've seen every Hunger Games
probably I mean I'm sure I did because
I've seen like all the last one but I
only really have ever rewatched like one
or the final one you know what happens
in the middle ones I no what happens at
the end does she end up with Peta or
Gabe she ends up with the little one
what yeah it's really shocking that's
wrong that's wrong because Liam
Hemsworth like go what's his name Gabe
Gail Gail gaale gaale yeah Liam
Hemsworth is Gil and he kind of like
gets a little um Nutty Nutty and like he
goes to work for the cap so basically
like they do the Revolution and when
they take over it's like they're not as
bad as snow but they're they're not
great either they like did Kill like I
think remember that Stampede into the No
No I remember nothing except I volunteer
as tribute like Liam got a little power
hungry you know what else I remember
it's so funny like what weird things
stick with you like that cream they were
given in the forest that like if you had
a gash on your leg the cream healed it
right up oh I don't remember that I just
remember how it ended it's like it's it
came down it was like this little like
looked like a la mer like a little tub
of cream and it came down on a little a
little parachute it was just so cute
yeah no that's so cute it didn't like
burn into my memory like for you oh of
course I also
remember of course I you remember
President Snow and his BL I loved Rue
right yeah and then yeah she ends up in
the countryside with the little
one having like saved the realm but but
still there's problems I think that was
the vibe I got it feels like a plot hole
like she ended up with the little one
yeah yeah doesn't doesn't sound right
cuz like in I remember being in the
theaters for the first movie or maybe
even the second movie cuz I think in the
first movie she never kissed Gail and
then I don't know what I think maybe in
the second movie is when she kissed Gail
and like people were like hooting and
hollering like thank God yay finally
like when you wait for like the two like
the obvious pair to go yeah no like Peta
was just a foil to Katniss and Gail's
relationship you know he was always just
me pet Jackie Peta was Jacob yeah yeah
but she ended up with him wrong yeah we
were talking a lot about this when we
did our fourth Wing episode for the
redheads because like you know she has
her mans and I'm just like is he the
Jacob or is he the Edward right before
the sequel yeah but even I remember when
we when we were watching Twilight and
maybe it's because the books had already
come out but like we knew Edward was
endgame it wasn't even a question
no we just knew because like we had eyes
on the situation and I thought I had
eyes on the situation in Hunger Games
but I guess I didn't no I mean I'm
pretty sure I've got it right I think
you're right too cuz I remember like
that's why I was disappointed and didn't
like keep watching it yeah yeah I'm like
oh these people have lost me Liam
Hemsworth doesn't win I'm out yeah okay
let me read the story because the
director said that he now understands
the mixed reactions to the final book
being divided into two films during an
interview with People magazine People
magazine is's just getting all the
interviews published on Friday the
filmmaker admitted that if he had to
redo the films he wouldn't split mocking
jay into two parts he said I totally
regret it I totally do I'm not sure
everybody does but I definitely do he
also noted that the team agreed at the
time that the two halves of mocking jay
which were released in theaters a year
apart had their own separate dramatic
questions which made for complete arcs
but he also acknowledged why some fans
weren't too happy with the long- awaited
period between films yeah that's wrong
to do and it just seems like money
hungry honestly it does it does but for
like a a fandom that's obsessed it
prolongs the fun and it's more content
like if they're both decently good
movies who cares yeah but if they're not
cuz I don't even remember like I know
Breaking Dawn part one was like the
pregnancy Breaking Dawn part two was
like that Revolution I don't know what
the difference between mocking jay part
one and two is like I feel like it was
the same storyline but just like on a
cliffhanger well that's wrong because
honestly like the way they ended part
one like there was so much substance in
part one I I don't know how they could
have made Breaking Dawn one movie yeah
no I agree it would have been silly like
so much happens in one movie like who is
the time yeah also remember with like
Philip Seymour Hoffman he passed away
yes before part two was done yeah they
they they handled that nicely but they
did that was really sad yeah it was he
was the best
yeah so that's what's going on in the
world of Hunger Games regrets M are you
ready for our next story no you're not
because our next story is brought to you
by the farmers dog the strice brother in
your life is the most important thing in
your life it's as simple simple and as
complicated as that and you want to make
sure that they are eating the best
possible foods and the healthiest foods
for them and that is why I switch to the
farmers's dog from kibble um when a
senior dog or any dog really at any age
but espeically a senior dog starts
acting like a puppy again and the
pickiest eaters can't wait for dinner
time you might think a spell was cast
but the farmer's dog doesn't use any
sorcery just fresh food and science so
the farmer's dog makes and delivers
Healthy dog food it's developed by vets
it's nutritionally balanced and it's
made from real healthy ingredients to
human food safety conditions it's the
best option for dogs at all life stages
because it's not kibble it's not canned
goo it's just real healthy food
traditional dry and wet food are options
are options that are highly processed
they can use much lower quality
ingredients than they claim to and they
are extremely difficult to portion
accurately but the farmer's dog is fresh
but it's not just fresh and high quality
they also send the food pre
pre-portioned specifically for your dog
based on their unique nutritional needs
this makes it easy to help your dog
maintain their ideal weight which is one
of the biggest indicators of a full
healthy life dogs at a healthy weight
can live up to 2 and a half years longer
than overweight dogs there's also a ton
of benefits like for me Theo's breath
was really bad and his poops were really
inconsistent and after after we switched
he's really on his like thin trim game
with good breath and normal size poops
so get 50% off your first box of fresh
healthy food at the farmers.com toast
plus you'll get free shipping when you
go to thefarmersdog.com toast that's
thefarmersdog.com toast to get 50% off
your first box and free shipping today's
episode is also brought to you by Babel
this fall start speaking a new language
with Babel why Babble you ask oh P it
works instead of paying hundreds of
dollars for a private tutor or fooling
yourself with language apps that are
little more than games Babel's quick
10-minute lessons are designed by over
150 language experts to help you start
speaking a new language in as little as
3 weeks Babel is designed by real people
for real conversations all of Babel's
tips and tools for learning a new
language are approachable accessible and
rooted in real life situations and
delivered with conversation best
technology so if you're planning a trip
abroad I think that's always a great
reason to start learning a new language
it's also just a great Hobby and thing
to challenge your mind in as you get
older you know it's hard to stimulate
the brain and babble so fun it's so easy
you know you can ask how to order food
ask for directions speak to Merchants
without having to consult a language app
while on vacation so studies from Yale
Michigan State University and others
continue to prove that Babble is just
better for instance one study found that
using Babble for 15 hours is equivalent
to a full semester at college with over
10 million Subs subscriptions sold
Babble is real language learning for
real conversations and here's a special
limited time deal for our listeners to
get you started right now and get 55%
off your Babel subscription only for our
listeners do so at babble.com toast get
55% off at babel.com toast spelled a BB
l.com toast babel.com
rules and restrictions May apply thank
you Babel for sponsoring today's episode
thank you Babel for being the best named
company in the world that too you like
the perfect name for a company doesn't
exist Babble Babble hold my
beer okay our next story is some really
great news for television Ken Jong of
mass singer The Hangover Community crazy
Rich agents Etc is shooting a talk show
pilot with debar Mercury so daytime may
be getting a new face Ken Jong has enter
entered the chat TV insiders are buzzing
that dear Mercury the production company
behind Sherry and Nick hannon's failed
talk show are working on a new project
with Shade that's page six for you okay
I didn't even realize that he had a fail
talk show did you never heard of it I
think that we it's coming back to me I
didn't realize that he had one I didn't
realize that it ended do you know what I
mean it's not even remotely in my brain
I never heard of it okay well they're
working on a new project with Nick
Cannon's Masked Singer castmate Dr Ken
Jong we hear Jong and debmar have been
trying to keep the nationally sated
project Under Wraps but they are
spending the weekend shooting the pilot
in the same Studio as Wendy Williams's
former set which now be belongs to the
Sherry Shepard show they're mum about it
but they're excited about putting him on
daytime even though they weren't able to
have success with Nick Cannon he just so
happens to be the host of mass singer
and Jong is one of the panelists on the
show he will will be an executive
producer of his new talk show sources
say everyone's been whispering about it
despite it being very top
secret okay daytime is so weird cuz it's
such a Dying Breed but they don't stop
like they can't be stopped and every now
and then they get something Kelly
Clarkson yeah and so Drew Barrymore too
I think that was actually like a really
unexpected thing that her show became as
popular as it was because it just seemed
like another woman with a show yeah um
and then they they they really haven't
stopped kuramo Jennifer Hudson I feel
Jennifer Hudson is like pretty popular
yeah they've done it like over 100
episodes and yeah she kind of flies
under the radar like just a consistently
like good audience good like uh ratings
yeah that's what you want like you never
want to be the most like buzzed about
like that's what daytime is supposed to
be just like consistency it's not the
flashiest it's not headlines every
single day like you're just a part of
people's lives yeah and so I feel like
she does a good job Ken Jong is like not
an obvious choice but when you really
sit down and think about it like he's
kind of America's sweetheart like he's
so beloved he's one of my favorite
actors everything that he's in like he
makes he's the reason why I'm laughing
we're rewatching community and like Ben
Chang there's just no one funnier
Claudia you I didn't realize he was in
community CL you have to watch singor
Chang he teaches Spanish class oh that's
funny no it's so funny um so I'm really
just in my Ken Jong era right now which
I always am because also like Leslie
Chow he's the reason why the hangover
movies are funny he's the reason why the
hangover movies are funny it's about
time somebody started saying that so I
think that he is a great pick for this I
really do I really feel like daytime
does a really good job of even if it
doesn't work out like finding people who
are just like so beloved who are more
than just actors but not like the
biggest baddest personality because then
you need to talk to other
people seriously like Kelly Clarkson
like that's exactly who she is yeah I
also feel like and I don't watch it so
I'm not familiar but like the mass
singer it really is huge and it's so
widespread like people all over America
like just tune in every week and he's
like one of the Stars he's really funny
and also he has a background in comedy
which I feel like when when you do
standup and like you're a writer you
really can do anything also he's a
doctor um which I think will add just a
level of expertise to his show and just
a different sort of flare and even maybe
he like takes over for Dr Phil Dr Jong
no not Dr Phil because Dr Phil is like a
PhD doctor like Dr Drew I mean Dr Oz
he's like a medical doctor true true so
yeah no and and Dr Drew I feel like all
those shows went off the air like those
medical talk shows we need a doctor yeah
but there's we don't need a doctor TV
show so the fact that he's like a
comedian a host and a doctor he brings
all different facets to life I actually
think the more we talk this through it's
an inspired Choice someone call the
doctor obvious someone call the doctor
the doctor is in the doctor is in and
when you are a daytime talk show host
like it's not enough to just be an actor
I think because
like it's it's just you need to be a
little more well-rounded like Kelly I
mean she does everything under the sun
she's saying she does her kellyoke like
maybe Ken Jung finds a way to bring in
his comedy his medical um expertise and
it brings a little something extra to
the show don't you think I do also
speaking of Kelly like she kind of lit
the internet of blaze in the last couple
of days cuz she's a snatchler because
she got a new stylist like I don't know
what the [__] yeah she like she looks
amazing she's wearing like cute clothes
and I don't think people realized until
she started dressing well that she's
been dressing [__] weird for like the
last couple of years like very um just
like frocks and patterns and you
know FR you're right about that she
loves a frock and it's like she's this
gorgeous young woman like Kelly if you
got it flaun it so people have noticed a
visible shift cuz she was on The Tonight
Show looking amazing in this black
jumpsuit and it's like wow why has Kelly
Clarkson never dressed like this before
and people are you know are led to
believe now that she is a new stylist I
love a a new stylist and she's look she
looks great she really does she's like
that's my queen right there yeah it
always comes back to Kelly like if
you're in Hollywood like Kelly like sets
the bar I would always just be like
comparing myself to Kelly it's true
queen queen are you ready for our fifth
and final story yes I'm just like was
looking for another story quickly but
this is an important one so I'll just
stick with it um a new Israeli
documentary is going to tell the story
of the mass at the Supernova Music
Festival so an Israeli documentary team
is already working on putting together a
documentary about what happened on
October 7th at the super noova Music
Festival in kboz raim um yariv Moser
director of The Devil's confession the
Lost Eman tapes and benu and epilog will
direct the film using exclusive material
from participants and key people at the
festival the filmmakers said they aim to
present an in-depth look at the festival
before during and after the horrific
event and will include interviews with
investigators soldiers and journalists
shocked by the Carnage they have
witnessed as well as unseen footage
gathered from the festival goers damn
that's rough um I have to say I watched
the segment this morning and just major
shout out to Anderson Cooper who like
will not let this go like he will not
stop telling stories about what happened
at that music festival and I saw I
watched this segment he did today I
think last night or the night before
they did an hour like a a pre-recorded
hour special on just the music festival
because so many more things are coming
out but in a teaser on his Regular Show
um he went down to one of the uh bomb
shelters so when when when people at the
festival started realizing like
something was going sideways they all
crammed into a bomb shelter roet it
happened Rockets were being fired so
Sirens went off so that you run to a
shelter right and there's a million
shelters like on every block in Israel
cuz this is something that they're used
to um so everybody ran to a shelter and
I think these terrorists knew that was
going to happen so they waited outside
and there was like filled to the brim
like packed in like sardines into these
bomb shelters and they threw grenades in
and blew people up and so uh Anderson
Cooper and a cameraman went to visit one
of the bomb shelters like the the
remains had been cleared up and his
cameraman like it was all on camera his
cameraman is vomiting profusely out like
he like the smell in there um he's doing
a really really amazing job like telling
stories of there's so many stories to
tell and it's like hard to get national
news coverage forever and I feel like
he's literally like doing his best every
single night like speaking with new
people um so shout out to him yeah and
like this is a story that is just so
horrible and really does need to be told
but it's going to be incredibly painful
to watch because it's so graphic yeah
but I think it's important I feel like a
lot of the people who might not be
paying the closest attention to what's
happened don't really know exactly like
how horrible it was and for our
generation like we consume a lot of
documentaries it's how people feel they
become experts on a certain matter like
it's true it's how people learn I think
it's the right for I think that's a
format that might grab people's
attention if it hasn't already you know
if they've just sort of like been
scrolling past what they've see or maybe
that they're just not being served it so
I think that putting it into a
documentary is a and you can pack a lot
of information and testimonies and photo
and video evidence into it like I think
it will begin to tell a part a big part
of the story about what happened I think
that's really important and the fact
that they're turning it around so
quickly like people need to know about
it now because like right it it has a
you know a huge amount to do with the
response that they're going to see from
Israel and you need to understand what
happened in order to have an opinion on
the response no and I feel like with
documentaries it's a lot of times about
things that happened in the past and
you're like well where was the outrage
and if the documentary had come out at
that time and galvanized the people then
maybe um it would have ended differently
and so now for the documentary to be
coming out you know in the time that it
actually did happen it's not telling the
story about something that happened 20
years ago it's impactful um so I think
this is good yeah I think it's um
necessary and I hope people watch and I
hope it's like available everywhere not
somewhere you have to go watch on like
no and not just available in Israel oh
yeah no but like you know Netflix Hulu
not like U some random Amon free free
yeah because um people need to know what
happened
so
yeah sorry to go back there but um I
thought it was interest and also just
like the way that Doc and we've been
seeing this even with things that happen
in popular culture you know Anna delie
or the GameStop stuff where the
documentary the turnaround time is
getting shorter and shorter but I think
with this like it it has a very
important purpose and that's to like
make people see sooner rather than later
yeah I
agree so those are the past five stories
lot of of content news actually four out
of five is content news it's good to be
back Jacks it really is it feels like
the writers are have gotten back to work
is what it is oh that is why there's so
much writing news except for um what was
it a past like Hunger Game stuff but
yeah the writers are back writing the
actors are not back acting and no update
even like it's not good so would SNL not
have come back this week if the writers
did it come back this week because the
writers um I don't know when they were
planning to but they if their release
date was I mean their premiere date was
anything in the past couple of weeks
then no um but who was the
host I don't know I only know Pete
Davidson but he was the host yeah he was
the host oh maybe because they couldn't
get someone in time right or they
couldn't get someone who has a project
out because that goes against sag like
you can't be promoting stuff and most
people do SNL when they're you know on a
movie promo yeah but what if you have
like a uh
it could have been a
podcaster yeah no I I wonder I'm sure
it's sag compliant but like why why Pete
was allowed was he promoting a movie no
maybe they just like the writer strike
ended they knew they could do a show in
in a week and a half and they couldn't
get someone to like do it and someone
who like wouldn't be Crossing sag yeah
no no no I know but I just might I'm
curious how Pete doing it isn't crossing
sag perhaps it's because he wasn't
promote anything and perhaps it's
because he's also technically a writer
yeah he's a writer right um and then ice
spice was the performer and then they
had Travis and Taylor so they turned out
a show no they did and I feel like it
was a good Premiere every everyone was
talking about
it yes but also because of Travis and
Taylor they kind of like saved their
little show uh they saved their little
Instagram
show um so those are the stories it's
nice to feel again you know yes you have
a big day ahead of you so I'm going to
let you go and do that thank you guys so
much for listening to the toast the M
Morning Show where we deliver the fast
five stories need to know every Monday
Friday on YouTube watching this on
YouTube please to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we also available
as podcast podcast be found so Spotify
radio box all the places listen podcast
find us the toar you better beautiful
stuning and wickedly talented we are
love you bye love you
bye